Tehran where people have been protesting
for days over the death last week of a
young woman after she was detained by
the notorious morality police with anger
sweeping the country hundreds have
reportedly been arrested and some even
killed as authorities tried to crack
down on the unrest in a speech at the
United Nations U.S President Joe Biden
praised the protesters courage saying
that Americans stood with the brave
women of Iran
we're fighting we're dying we're going
to get Iran back one of the many cries
rallying the thousands of people pouring
onto Iran's streets this week the
protests have rocked the country and
seem to be only intensifying a number of
people have been killed in clashes as
Security Forces tried to clamp down on
the unrest there are reports of Internet
blackouts too to stop information from
flowing the protests are being driven by
acute anger over the death of Masa amini
the 22 year old died while being held by
Iran's morality police accused of
wearing the hijab in a way deemed
improper Iran's authorities have
promised to investigate amini's death
but many people are skeptical and fed up
with the morality police for them
amini's death symbolizes Iran's
heavy-handedness towards descent and the
increasingly violent treatment of women
in the Islamic Republic
let's bring in yalda zarbach she's the
head of DW's Persian service and joins
me from cologne this is not the first
time women in Iran protests against
hijab laws but the country's never seen
anything like this has it
yes that's um that's absolutely right
what we are witnessing right now is a a
different dimension of protests as to
say
um it's very very um we've seen it now
also we have seen it in the report it's
very amazing it's um amazingly Brave I
have to say first of all by by the
Iranian women we see them on the streets
protesting
um without hijab without the mandatory
headscarf waving their head scarves we
have seen women on on the streets during
the protest cutting their hairs and this
is something that we have not witnessed
before there has been a lot of protests
in Iran in recent years basically the
last 40 years we've we've could witness
every 10 years kind of protest and um
recently it it was the biggest protest
was 2009 but then we have 2018 we had
2019 due to inflation
um due to the increase of fuel prices
but this time it's different because
it's kind of reunites
all people from all different different
classes different ideologies
religious or non-religious people yeah
the death of masamini also struck a
chord with women because they pretty
much all have experience with the
morality police can you tell us what
role they play in everyday life
you know the morality police is
basically
um this is something that women girls
women in Iran last 40 years have grown
up with and it is part of their everyday
life though I have to say
um there are there are um periods where
you see them a lot you know on the
streets and um and taking women with
them uh onto the police station and they
have this special police station of the
morati police where masamini was taken
to as well
um and there is also periods where you
know for instance before election time
um it's more like people can you know
women can be dressed they the way they
are
um but the thing is that this happens
all the time we have seen in the last
weeks actually a lot of videos that have
reached us where we see how how wildly
violently sorry
um the women are taken into the police
cars and then now the outrage is uh so
it's so huge also because the it that
has been Masa mini has been a really
like innocent young girl
um she was not taking part in a protests
she was not you know following any uh
ideology she was just visiting the
capital Tehran and then um being taken
to by the by the morality police and the
outrage is also because the official
statement is the
um that she had a heart attack and of
course no one is willing to believe that
because they have experienced this
violence by morality police we only have
about a half a minute left but I want to
ask you if you think that this could
become a watershed moment for women in
Iran
it definitely could
um we have to see if there has if there
will be a um a harder Crackdown or in
which direction this will go yeah she's
the head of DW's Persian service thank
you so much for those insights tonight
thank you